alright guys remember loki esports
they're the org that owed their players
and staff more than a hundred and thirty
seven thousand dollars in late payments
well after failing to meet their latest
final date for repayment a ton of other
players and staff have come out of the
woodwork contacted me and told me about
considerable sums of money they are
still owed since then I've been in
contact with Riot Games I've reached out
to the orcs owners and have talked to a
lawyer
here's what happens next
[Music]
okay so what was about three weeks ago
when I first reported on the low-key
eSports incident now in case you're not
up on Loki they're a global eSports
brand that has teams all across the
world some of them are fairly
insignificant
some of them though like they're League
of Legends team and they're rocket
League squad have made their games
respective world championships one key
are the real deal coming into our LCS
season eight world champion making
history for the South American region
Loki there was one major problem though
loki esports owed their players and
staff globally well over a hundred and
thirty seven thousand dollars long story
short since about october of 2019 loki
esports have owed people a lot of money
they failed to communicate with those
people in a responsible manner they have
failed on multiple promises for
repayment and have put a lot of young
people looking to break into esports in
a pretty shitty situation since we first
released that initial report three
things happen
number one a ton of different people
came out of the woodwork to tell me
about money that they are still owed and
i mean a ton to Gerena the company
license to distribute League of Legends
in the Southeast Asia region took
matters into their own hands more on
that later three I was able to nail down
a hard deadline from one of the owners
Tony nuyen for final repayment of money
owed by loki esports that date for final
repayment was sunday january 26 so what
happened well unfortunately not
everybody got paid in fact a lot of
people didn't get paid some individuals
a few of them among the most publicly
vocal and a few of them who appeared on
record in my last video on the subject
did get their money by sunday and a few
got their money only after the deadline
and after they persistently bothered
management about it but at least they
got it unfortunately many people didn't
including their South American rocket
league team that made the World
Championships in season seven and
Nate last year but they're far from the
only ones as of this recording here are
just some of the people who told me they
haven't got their money social media
managers Brazilian Rainbow six siege
players from the female division
South American rocket league players and
staff designers Brazilian csgo staff na
apex legends players certain Regional
Managers pop G players staff working for
Loki in Korea and more all of those
people were supposed to be paid they
weren't and those are just the people
that I'm in contact with at this point
it seems some former low key players and
staff are starting to take matters into
their own hands for example the manager
of Loki's former Brazilian csgo team
told me that he and a number of other
individuals who formerly worked for Loki
are consulting with a lawyer about
potential legal action and it's worth
noting here guys that since my initial
video came out a ton of people have
reached out to me and told me horror
stories that aren't even related to the
hundred thirty seven thousand dollars
including some that go back to Loki
studio / GG easy the video editing arm
of Loki now I mentioned earlier that
Gerena the company that distributes
League of Legends in Southeast Asia is
looking into the situation basically one
of Loki's most successful teams which is
their League of Legends squad is based
in Vietnam which is of course in that
region
they came 17 xx at Worlds last year I
received information a short time ago
that Gerena and potentially riot games
themselves are putting very serious
pressure on Loki I reached out to Riot
Games to try and discern the nature of
this pressure what is actually going on
behind the scenes and here are a few
statements they sent to me from their
colleagues at Gerena hi Colin thank you
for reaching out it's important to
clarify that Riots interaction with Loki
eSports is in regards to the Loki
eSports team competing in Vietnam in the
League of Legends of Vietnam
championship series the CS we have no
insight into the ongoings of their
global org outside of Vietnam including
Loki teams competing in other games /
eSports Riot Games and Gerena are
publishing partner for League of Legends
in Southeast Asia Taiwan Hong Kong and
Macau worked diligently to ensure that
all teams comply with our global
League operations policies including
upholding financial commitments to their
players I further reached out for more
clarification on what exactly this means
and here's what I got
quote we are working with Loki to ensure
adherence to our global league
operations policies and quote so what
can we take from those statements well
it's tough to tell obviously something
is going on behind the scenes that much
is clear but exactly what Gerena and
riot won't say at this time
but according to information provided to
me by multiple sources with knowledge of
the situation it is entirely possible
that Loki eSports will be kicked out of
the VCS by riot now this particular
information has come to me very recently
should I find out more
should I get a confirmation you'll be
the first to know so what about the
owners of Loki eSports where are they in
all of this well I've been in let's call
it intermittent contact through Twitter
DMS with one of them by the name of Tony
nuyen now Tony is the one who gave me
the latest final repayment deadline that
was Sunday January 26 I reached out to
him about the missing money the blown
deadline and Riot Games and gharanas
involvement in this situation he sent me
the following statement
I personally been dealing with slash
communicating with players slash staff
and working to get their payments out
many of which have already been paid the
management on the Loki eSports side has
been at constant work to get things in
order I am doing what I can do to assist
them since as stated before I run the
marketing and media side more of the
other businesses there are players yet
to be paid but we are covering one team
at a time we are all different companies
from Loki community to Loki eSports but
we help each other regardless I
personally am NOT going anywhere and
will continue to represent this brand
along with a many hard-working staff and
talent the mistakes of one company will
reflect on the others and we understand
that all players and staff are open to
DM me I will continue resolving the
issues every day - every second now he's
not actually an owner but I also reached
out to max wood who during this entire
process has been
the middleman communicating between
low-key management and ownership and
low-key staff and players I asked him
about the blown deadlines for repayment
and what he said to me was quote from
what I've been told
payments have been going out and people
are being paid slowly albeit I've been
sent screenshots and confirmed with some
managers slash teams I also asked him to
confirm some of that more i popping
information about Gerena and Riot Games
involvement now he wouldn't tell me
anything specific but he did acknowledge
the possibility of low-key eSports
being removed from the VCS from League
of Legends in Vietnam now I said earlier
that a group of former players and staff
have been consulting with a lawyer to
see if there's a legal recourse to
everything that's happened to them on
Loki and the legality of this entire
situation has been on my mind throughout
the weeks that I've been reporting on
Josh Marcus of mkm a toronto-based law
firm that specializes in eSports told me
that people who are a part of Loki or
have been who haven't been paid yet
and our owed money could conceivably
have a case so to speak the question as
he pointed out to me is whether or not
it's actually worth it when you're
getting money late you could probably
make an argument that you should be
getting some interest on that you know
we're talking not a lot of interests
maybe 3% over a year that's you know
then brought down to about three months
and you know you're kind of left ok at
what point is it worth pursuing a case
but certainly you know if you're not
paid whatsoever
yeah that's your buddy course your
recourse is to the courts to dispute
resolution to really prove that there is
that breach of contract this is
especially true in the Loki situation
because a lot of the affected people are
pretty young they don't have the money
necessarily to hire a lawyer
they don't have the money to pay for
court filings they don't have the time
to take off work or school to represent
themselves so I asked Josh the eSports
lawyer what do you do if you're 19 years
old you're trying to live the eSports
dream
and something like this happens the
first step is really when you get that
contract before you sign it either have
a lawyer another legal professional and
eSports coach somebody who is very
familiar with the industry and how these
contracts should be written just have a
look at it even if it's a matter of
pointing out what you're agreeing to you
know there's often little red flags that
are hidden in there or things that are
Mis drafted that really could come back
to bite you at the end once you're
already signed in and you're at this
point you know keeping a constant
communication trail keeping things in
writing wherever possible even if that's
discord or text message you know
something that just shows the position
or the situation that you've been put in
all of that can help down the line you
know it's hard to tell how the whole
industry will unfold but certainly you
know there's no reason not to be
protecting your rights at the stage and
then even if it's a matter of writing to
the team and bugging them every month
and saying where's my money you're at
least showing that hey I haven't
forgotten about this you know this this
should be there and if the team's gonna
be successful they're gonna want to make
sure that they're paying you out
otherwise you know they get a lot of bad
press if you ask me who can challenge a
straw Louis yeah Team Liquid yeah
mousesports can give them a little run
for their money I still don't really
fully believe they could be distraught
us in the long term I want to see the
likes of Xero and the likes of simple on
teams on which that enable them to
succeed I want to see them fight a straw
I want to see the ultimate five-man unit
versus the ultimate individual frag fest